اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
تعليق العمل بمعاهده ستارت للحد من انتشار
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه وقال ان بلاده تواجه
خطرا وجوديا وفي خطاب القهوا امام الجمعيه
البرلمانيه الروسيه اضاف بوتين انه من
المستحيل هزيمه روسيا في ارض المعركه وان
بلاده قامت بكل ما يمكن لمعالجه المساله
مع اوكرانيا بطرق السلبيه
ان النخبه الغربيه لا تخفي اهدافها يريدون
كما يقولون ان يقوم بضربات استراتيجيه ضد
روسيا ماذا يعني هذا لنا هذا يعني انهم
يريدون ان يلهونا مره والى الابد يريدون
ان يستخدموا النزاع القطاعي ليتحول الى
حرب شامله هذا ما يقومون به
سوف تكون رده فعلنا متناسبه مع هذا
العدوان لان الحديث الان عن وجود دولتنا
مراسلتنا
تعليق العمل بمعاهده
ستارت ورسائل قويه اخرى ومواقف اخرى من
اعلن عنها بوتين قبل قليل نعود واياك الى
ابرزها
اه نعم وسيله يعني من بين اهم الاحداث من
اهم الاخبار اللي انصحها التعبير التي
صدرت لهذا اليوم وهي تعليق روسيا لاحد اهم
الاتفاقات الاستراتيجيه ما بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده وهذه الاتفاقيه هي
معاهده ستارت او معاهده الحد من الاسلحه
الهجوميه الاستراتيجيه يمكن القول هذه
المعاهده هي اخر معاهده بين البلدين من
شانها يعني الرقابه على التسلح النووي في
العالم لاسيما بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا واليوم بوتين اعلن عن تعليقه
بالاشاره ايضا الى انه الى ضروره ان تضم
هذه
الاتفاقيه دول حلف شمال الاطلسي هنا اود
الاشاره الى ان الولايات المتحده بدورها
كانت قد طالبت في عهد الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامبي ضم الصين الى هذه المعاهده
كونها هي الاخرى تملك اسلحه نوويه ولكن
اليوم بوتين في ظل هذه الاحداث في ظل حسب
تعبيره الاعلان الرسمي من قبل دول حلف
شمال الاطلسي والاسيما الولايات المتحده
وهي عزمها بالحاق روسيا بالهزيمه
الاستراتيجيه على الارض في ظل هذه
التصريحات العلانيه فان روسيا اكدت اولا
انها لن توافق ابدا على العوده لمساله
التفتيش تفتيش المنشات العسكريه النوويه
في روسيا لن تسمح للولايات المتحده بفعل
ذلك في اطار هذه المعاهده وعليه وانطلاقا
من ذلك فهي تعلقها لاسيما وان الولايات
المتحده هي الاخرى لم تسمح لروسيا
يعني اجراء عمليات التفتيش التي تنص عليها
هذه المعاهده اود الاشاره لانه وفقا لهذه
المعاهده سنويا تجري كل من روسيا
والولايات المتحده
عشره عمليات تفتيش من النوع الاول اي
تفتيش
للمواقع التي تنتشر فيها الاسلحه والانظمه
الاستراتيجيه النوويه وايضا من عمليات
تفتيش من النوع الثاني وهي الرقابه
والتفتيش المواقع التي تضم على انظمه
استراتيجيه يعني هذه الرساله يعني مباشره
موجهه للدول الغربيه اولا وسيله مفادها ان
روسيا متمسكه ومصممه على موقفها النقطه
الثانيه وهي ان روسيا لن تتراجع على
الاطلاق لا فيما يتعلق به الازمه والصراع
في اوكرانيا ولا فيما يتعلق بعلاقاتها مع
دول الغرب لاسيما وانها اعلنت في العديد
من المناسبات وايضا الرئيس الروسي فلادي
تحدث عن ذلك كثيرا ان حلف الناتو على راس
الولايات المتحده هي يعني طرف مباشر في
الصراع على الارض في اوكرانيا وعليه فان
هذه الاتفاقيات تم تعليقها الى ان يتم
الاخذ في عين الاعتبار بكل هذه النقاط
فيما يتعلق بضم الدول جديده دول في حلف
شمال الاطلسي هذه المعاهده ايضا فيما
يتعلق بمساله تفتيش المنشات النوويه روسيا
اشارت واكدت انها هي الاخرى تريد عمليه ان
تسمح لها الولايات المتحده بهذه العمليات
والتي كانت قد علقتها هذا من جهه من جهه
اخرى هناك ايضا رسائل اخرى تتعلق بالصراع
على الارض اوكرانيا وهنا الحديث يدور فيما
يتعلق
بقراءه القرارات الغربيه بارسال اسلحه
بعيده المدى للجانب الاوكراني والتي
يمكنها استهداف الاراضي الروسيه في هذا
الاطار ايضا كانت هناك انذارات واضحه
المعالم اليوم الرئيس الروسي وجهها للدول
الغربيه في اطار خطابه السنوي امام
الجمعيه البرلمانيه الروسيه مفادها انه
كلما زاد الغرب بتزويد اوكرانيا بمثل هذه
الاسلحه اسلحه كلما اضطرت روسيا لتوسيع
عمليتها العسكريه مما يضمن امنها وامن
اراضيها الوسيله شكرا جزيلا لك رانيا
دريدي مراسله
كما قال الرئيس الروسي بلاده قامت بكل ما
هو ممكن لحل مشكله دومباس سلميا لكن الغرب
عد سيناريو مختلف
كنا نقوم بكل شيء ممكن لحل هذا ان اللعب
بطرق سلميه كنا بصبر نقوم بالمفاوضات حتى
نخرج من هذا النزاع الاصعب ولكن وراء
ظهورنا كانوا يحضروا سيناريو اخر وكان
كانت وعود القيادات
الاوروبيه بتحقيق السلم في الدنباط كل هذا
كان خدعه وكذب كانوا
يستفيدوا من الوقت ويمد الوقت ويغمض
اعينهم على الجرائم
السياسيه
والاضطهاد من قبل
الاوكرانيين
وتعذيب المتدينين كل هذا كان اعمال
ارهابيه في الدباس من قبل نظام كيف النادي